hello and welcome to the DevOps
prerequisite course the one course that
you must go through before starting your
DevOps or cloud journey my name is
Muhammad Muhammad and I will be your
instructor for this course students who
are absolute beginners and are totally
new to IT or the cloud and DevOps world
requires some additional help in
starting their journey for example they
often run into issues with setting up a
basic lab environment using VirtualBox
or issues with configuring the right
kind of networking in VirtualBox or
trouble with working with the Linux CLI
or text editors like VI editor and
sometimes it's trouble with getting a
web server to communicate with a
database server or at other times it's
working with data formats like JSON or e
mo so we have identified a gap and we
believe that this is because they are
missing some of the basic prerequisites
as a DevOps or cloud engineer it is
important to have these basics cleared
and that's why we built this course to
bridge that gap this course helps you
get your basics right so the rest of the
journey is smooth now you might be
wondering whether you have the
background or the experience to get
started and I want to assure you that
this course is really for anyone who
wants to start their DevOps or cloud
journey even if you're from a non IT
background or you don't have a computer
science degree or if you are a college
student who has no work experience and
wants to start your DevOps or cloud
journey this course is also for those
who happen to have some experience such
as developers who wants to learn a
little bit about operations in order to
move to a DevOps role so no coding or
programming knowledge required so how
does it work with visual learning we
simplify complex concepts using
illustrations and animations and we have
demos where we show you how to put these
into practice we have hands-on labs that
open up right in your browser where we
have pre-configured environments for you
to practice with our labs are
fun and interactive and hassle-free you
don't need to do anything to get them to
work they just work right in your
browser you'll learn by exploring real
environments and solving puzzles and
you'll troubleshoot and fix broken
environments and we will always verify
your work and we'll give you feedback on
what went wrong at any time you feel
stuck we have a community where you can
get help so let's get started and I will
see you in the next video so let's take
a closer look at the objectives of this
course remember that this is a DevOps
and cloud prerequisites course so this
is the course that comes before you
start an actual DevOps course and since
we cover a lot of concepts we will cover
just enough of each topic so you have a
fair idea about that topic as well as
get some cancel and experience in the
first section we start with the basics
of Linux where you go through and
understand basic commands in the Linux
CLI you'll learn how to work with the VI
editor as it's important to be
comfortable with at least one text
editor in Linux you'll use this when you
work with files in Linux such as
configuration files we then look at how
to install software and dependencies in
Linux and then we will see what our
services and how to configure them at
times you may want to set up your own
personal lab environment an environment
where your changes are saved and an
environment where you can develop your
own custom solutions and this section
will help you create your own lab as
well as troubleshoot and maintain it
which is something that most students
struggle with especially the networking
part in worship box and we have some
neat lectures and demos that explain
those another area that students usually
struggle is with networking in Linux how
our interfaces and IP address is
configured why can't I get a VM to reach
the internet or multiple VMs to ping
each other how do I configure routing
what is DNS and how do I configure the
right DNS settings and how do I
troubleshoot DNS related issues and we
covered these along with labs in this
section we also look at some of the
commonly used data structure languages
like JSON and
mo automation tools like ansible use
llamo to develop playbooks and docker
and kubernetes use it for building
definition files so we have a lot of fun
challenges that will help you practice
this well let's get started when you're
ready
in this section we'll go through some of
the basics of linux command line if
you're already as linux maestro then
feel free to skip this section or simply
go through the labs and try to complete
the challenges and make sure you're
comfortable with all of them while
designing this course we used stack
overflows in sites along with the data
from service we conducted from our
student base and which you might have
seen in our other courses to identify
the most commonly used and most
demanding technologies that we will
cover in this course that way we can
make this course relevant to most of you
so you'll see me referring to these
often and I hope learning the most loved
and wandered technologies will motivate
you as per stack overflows insights the
most common and the most loved platform
used for development work happens to be
Linux if you are from a Windows
background I'd highly recommend learning
some Linux basics as most DevOps tools
have a requirement for Linux as part of
this course we cover basics of Linux OS
such as how to work with the command
line interface how to work with text
editors like VI editor we discuss
package management and services etc
there are different flavors of Linux
such as Ubuntu Red Hat Enterprise Linux
CentOS etc we conducted a survey of our
students and a good percentage of them
requested their preferred OS to be
CentOS followed by Ubuntu and Red Hat
Enterprise Linux CentOS is a free
community edition of Red Hat Enterprise
Linux so learning Central's also helps
you cover the basics of RHEL Learning
Centres will also help you prepare for
Linux certifications like Linux
essentials or Linux foundations
certified systems administrator
certification now since you also cover a
basics of Red Hat Enterprise Linux it
also helps you prepare for any Red Hat
exams and that's why we decided that
CentOS is going to be the OS of our
choice
for this course so let us begin our
Linux crash course in this section
you're going to work with Linux systems
in our lab this is so you get very
familiar with the Linux CLI and some
basic commands before you actually
deploy a Linux system by yourself the
next section is about deploying a Linux
system on your Linux laptop using tools
like VirtualBox when you do that the CLI
and commands you learn in this section
will be handy so I recommend not
deploying your own Linux system for now
instead just rely on our labs and get
some good hands-on practice and then in
the next section deploy your own VMs so
we will start assuming a Linux system
has already been provisioned let's start
with Shell Linux systems have both CLI
and GUI interfaces when you work with
Linux
especially in IT you work with the CLI
and you must get really comfortable with
it because most servers that you work
with in your work environment won't
really have a graphical user interface
so we will just focus on the command
line the text-based command line
interface that helps you run commands to
interact with the operating system is
called the Linux shell
if you have ever worked on a Linux
system before you might have noticed
that sometimes the CLI interface behaves
differently as in sometimes you press
the backspace button to delete a command
and it doesn't work or when you press
the tab button to autocomplete it
doesn't autocomplete and that's because
there are different kinds of shells such
as the bourne shell the c shell c shell
bourne-again shell which is known as
bash and each of these shells behave
differently
the older shell which is the bourne
shell or simply known as shell had
limitations in the way we interact with
it the newer bash shell supports many
advanced features such as arithmetic
operations conditionals arrays etc you
can see which shell you are on by
printing the environment variable name
shell using the echo
dollar shell command the echo command
helps you print on the screen and the
dollar symbol helps you specify an
environment variable let's now get
introduced to some basic Linux commands
we will first look at the commands and
you will then work on labs where you
will use these commands echo as we just
discussed is the command used to print a
line of text the word you enter after
the echo command will be printed on your
screen as simple as that the echo
command is usually used when you want to
print out an environment variable as we
just saw we will discuss about
environment variables later the echo
command is also used in scripts where
you want to print out information onto
screen the LS command is used to list
all the contents of a directory here we
see that we have two files file dot txt
and file to conf and a directory named
my underscore dir one the CD command
stands for change directory and it is
used to navigate to new directories in
the system for example to get into the
my underscore dir one directory run the
command CD followed by the directory
name the PWD command or the present
working directory command is used to
print the directory you are currently in
the mkdir or the make directory command
is used to create a new directory in
this example we've created a new
directory called new underscore
directory to run multiple commands one
after the other separate them by a
semicolon in this case it first changes
into the new directory then makes a
directory by the name www and then
prints the current working directory now
even though it's a single execution
remember there are three separate
commands and executed one after the
other at times you might want to create
a directory tree for example we want to
create a directory slash TMP slash Asia
slash India slash Bangalore one way to
do that
is to run the make directory command
three times specifying one directory
each time for example first we create
the first directory and then we create
the India directory in inside Asia and
then we create the Bangalore directory
inside India a better way to do that
would be to run a single command using
the - P option like this this way it
creates the entire directory tree in one
shot and does not complain if a
particular directory is not available
to remove a directory and all of its
contents run the RM - or command and
specify the directory name to copy one
directory to another location use the CP
command but with the - R option this
copies the directory and all of its
contents from one location to another
let's see some commands to work with
files to create a new file run the touch
command and provide the file name this
creates a new file but with no contents
to add some contents to the file use the
cat command and the redirection symbol
which looks like a forward arrow
followed by the file name once this
command is issued the prompt will wait
for your user input you would be able to
add lines of text hit the return key to
typing into a new line of text and press
the ctrl D combination to exit out of
this prompt and save the data to the
file to view the contents of a file run
the cat command followed by the file
name this time without the redirection
symbol these are some basic commands to
work with files in the CLI for editing
contents of a file you may need a text
editor like VI or vim we also take a
look at the basics of VI editor later in
this course
now while working with DevOps tools you
often come across situations where you
will have to modify configuration files
on Linux and these editors will come
handy then but to get through this
lecture and the following labs you don't
really need a text editor so let's
continue to copy a file use the CP
command
and specify the source file path and
name and the target path and name to
move a file which is similar to cutting
and pasting a file to a different
location use the MV command specify the
old name and the new path and the file
name if the file is moved to the same
path but with a different name then is
essentially like renaming the file and
that is how you rename a file in Linux
there's no separate command for that run
the RM command to remove or delete a
file so that's about it for this section
head over to the labs and practice
working with these basic Linux commands
let me quickly introduce you to the
hands-on labs in this course the lab
interface is divided into two sections
here you have a terminal which is a live
terminal to a Linux host and here you
have a quiz portal it takes a few
minutes for the labs to load so just
give it some time if you need more space
for your lab click on this button here
to hide the curriculum window that way
you can get a more space for your lab so
we'll just wait for it to load okay so
the lab is loaded and I'm on the Linux
terminal here and this is my quiz portal
in the quiz portal I have various tasks
that I am expected to complete the tasks
are of two kinds first we have
exploratory questions which are these
where we ask you to explore the
environment and and select the right
answers from these options let me walk
you through a few of these questions in
this case this is a multiple-choice
question so here you have a question and
here you have some options who you're
supposed to select the right option in
case you are not sure how to find the
answer to that question we have some
hints so clicking on this will tell you
exactly what you need to do it will give
you the command that you need to run or
hint to find the right solution we also
have a timer so these labs are available
for an hour each time so you can access
these labs as many times as you want but
each time there's a time limit like sits
in an hour and this lab session also has
a number of questions and you can see
the question numbers here currently we
are on the first question and this lab
has a total of 10 questions you can also
skip through questions in case you go
through five questions and then for some
reason you had to stop or for some
reason the lab terminates in that case
you can restart the lab and then you can
skip through the questions so let's
start with let me show you a few
examples in this case we have the
question is how many directories and
files are present in the home
Thor test directory so we go to that
particular directory here
okay and then we list the contents and
we see that there are three directories
and then three files okay so the correct
answer is three directories and three
files and that's correct
next the question is which text file is
not present under the Home Tour
directory so we know that there is files
one two and four so three is not is the
correct answer but let's say you pick
the wrong answer and then it's going to
tell you that it's wrong so you must
select the correct answer and the next
question is to create its now this is a
task so this is the second type of
question which is not a multiple choice
question so here you have to perform the
tasks that you're asked to do and if you
don't do it and it's going to check your
work and it's going to tell you that the
task is not completed so in this case we
have to create a file under the Home
Tour directory so we use the touch
command and we create the file you can
always refer to the the course material
the PDF to get the correct answer or you
can refer to the hint so here I create
an empty file using the touch command
when I check it's successful okay so
these are very basic labs and as and
when you go through the course the
difficulty will increase and you'll have
more and more complex tasks and
challenges to complete now for some
reason if you would like to open a new
terminal here there are some options so
if you click on the plus button and
click on open your terminal then you can
get a new terminal window so here I have
the old terminal and here I have the new
one and if you are at some point in time
we will be hosting web servers and if
you would like to access the URL of the
server then you have to click these
links and that way it'll open up a new
browser and it will forward your request
to the host what you're accessing is at
Terminal two every mode server I hope
you enjoy your learning let us now look
at some more Linux commands that will
help you get through this course we will
start with
user accounts to know which user you are
run the Who am I I command in this case
it says you are user Matthew the ID
command gives you more information about
the user such as the users ID which
happens to be one zero zero one and the
group ID and the groups that the user is
part of to switch from one user to
another you may use the SU command su
stands for switch user to switch to user
say a Poorna run the SU command followed
by the user's name you will then be
prompted for the user's password if
you're accessing one system from another
system using se SSH and you want to log
in to the other system using a different
user than your current user specify the
user name before the host name followed
by an @ symbol when it comes to
performing tasks not all users can do
all tasks in Linux
Mathieu is a regular user and so his
access on the system is restricted every
Linux system has a super user known as
the root user the root user has no
restrictions on the system and can
perform any task which is why in most
production environments or enterprise
environments access to the root user is
restricted and you will almost never
login to the systems as a root user now
as a normal user what if you wish to
perform actions that can only be
performed by a root user such as
installing and configuring software and
services on the system or viewing
certain paths such as the root directory
a root user can make that possible for a
regular user by granting them sudo
privileges by making an entry into the
Etsy sudoers file so the user is still a
regular user but with root privileges
when a regular user is granted sudo
privilege they can now elevate their
permission level and perform tasks that
they otherwise couldn't by simply
prefixing
a command with the keyword pseudo
they'll be asked for their password and
on entering the password the command is
executed when you look through the labs
in the rest of this course you'll work
in an environment where you will not
have root access instead you will be a
regular user with sudo privileges so
while making changes to the system you
must remember to use the sudo prefix if
not you will get permission denied
errors so whenever you hit permission
denied errors remember that it could be
because you haven't used these pseudo
prefix we will be discussing about a lot
of commands through the rest of this
course and for the sake of brevity we
won't be specifying the sudo prefix each
time on all our slides so it is assumed
that you will use this prefix while
working in the labs let us now look at
some commands that will help us download
files from the internet
at times you will have to download files
from the internet such as RPM packages
or binary files or images and you can
use use the Col command and provide the
URL of the file to download the file add
the dash capital o option to save the
result to a file otherwise it'll just
print the file on screen another tool
that can be used to download files is
the W get command again specify the full
URL and with the dash capital o options
specify the name of the file that you
want it to store locally as at times you
may be on a Linux system and may not
know what operating system you are on to
know the current OS inspect the release
files under the Etsy directory the
release files may be named differently
based on the operating system so use a
wild-card like this to see more details
about the OS view these files by running
the cat command and you can see that in
this case it's CentOS version 7 let's
not talk about package managers in Linux
package managers
help you install various software on the
Linux system and when you go through
DevOps and cloud courses you will
install various software such as web
servers database servers and DevOps
tools or dependent software's and most
of these are installed using package
managers CentOS uses an RPM based
package manager just like Red Hat and
press Linux or Fedora rpm stands for red
hat package manager a software is
packaged into a bundle with the
extension Tod RPM to install the package
use the RPM command and the - i option
for install and specify the package name
- uninstall a package use the - e option
and to query the database and get
details about an installed package use
the - cue option so rpm requires you to
point it to the exact location where the
RPM package is available you then
install that package on the system it
does not care about any dependencies
that this package may have for example
say you were installing another software
like ansible
and it requires python and other other
dependent software so simply installing
ansible with the RPM command would not
take care of installing python and other
dependent libraries if they are all not
already installed and that's why you
need a solution that can make these easy
for you a single command that can query
the package find its location and
install all dependencies as well as the
package itself
that's where package managers like yum
come into play yum is a high level
package manager that uses RPM underneath
running a simple yum install ansible
command installs ansible and all of its
dependent packages yum searches software
repositories that act as warehouses
containing hundreds and thousands of RPM
package files
these repositories can be local that is
installed on your laptop for example or
on a remote location either a secure
server in your enterprise or available
publicly in the Internet
under the hoods yum still makes use of
the RPM package manager so when you try
to install a package using yum yum
searches these repositories finds the
required packages and dependencies and
installs all of them in the right order
so what is this remote repository and
how our packages stored there like how
does yum find where a particular package
is located the information about the
repository in a configuration file at
path slash Etsy / yum repose dot d
directory every operating system comes
bundled with its own set of repositories
from which you can install a lot of
commonly used software and tools so you
might not need to edit the list of
repositories but at times the default
set of repositories may not have the
software you need or may not have the
latest version of software that you need
to install so in that case you will need
to configure additional repositories so
that yum can find those packages
instructions to configure additional
repositories are usually made available
along with the software itself and we'll
see an example of that so to see the
list of repositories available on a
system run the young rapid list command
and here we see that there are a set of
CentOS repositories such as the base and
extra repository as well as MongoDB and
MySQL ones so listing the files under
the Etsy MDOT riposte
directory shows the files where these
repositories are configured and if you
look inside one of these files you will
see the URL of the location where all
packages are stored now if you visit
this URL you can see the RPM files that
yum will eventually download and install
on your local system with the RPM
utility
so that's kind of how young finds a
package in this case since we are
relying on an existing yum repo on
CentOS it takes us to an older version
of ansible which happens to be version
2.4 although the latest version as of
this recording is 2.9 so as I just
mentioned the instructions to configure
the repo to install the latest version
of ansible
is available in the ansible
documentation page itself so you can
configure a new report using the yum
install command itself and running this
command adds a new repository to your
system which points to the latest
version of ansible to see a list of
installed or available packages run the
yum list command and followed by the
package name if you want to search for
its particular package it provides the
package name and version and if it's an
installed package or just an available
package to remove an installed package
run the yum remove command followed by
the package name and to list all
available versions of a package run the
young list command but this time with
the show duplicates option so here we
see two versions of packages for ansible
and we can see that each of these are
from two separate repositories one is
from the extras repository and the other
is from the EPL repository to install a
specific version of a package run the
yum install command with the package
name followed by a hyphen and the
version of the package let's now talk
about services in Linux once you install
a software on servers especially those
that run in the background such as web
servers or database servers you would
need to make sure that those servers or
services are running and that they stay
running even after the servers are
rebooted so services in Linux help you
configure software to run in the
background and make sure that they run
all the time automatically when
servers are rebooted as well as they
follow the right order of startup when
any software that runs as a service in
the background is installed such as a
web server or database server or devops
tools like docker they're automatically
configured as a service on the system to
start that service you run the service
start command and providing the service
name which happens to be in this case
httpd the newer method to start a
service is to use the system cuddle
command and run the system cuddle start
command and provide the service name so
in this case system cuddle or systemctl
start httpd system cuddle is the command
used to manage services on a system the
managed server both the commands at the
service command and the system cuddle
command serve the same purpose the
service command uses the system cuddle
utility underneath so we will just focus
on using the system cuddle command for
the remainder of this lecture to stop a
running service run the system cuddle
stop command followed by the service
name to check the status of a service
run the system cuddle status command to
configure a service to start
automatically when the system boots up
run the system cuddle enable command and
to disable the service at boot up run
the system cuddle disabled command once
services are configured it is so
convenient for administrators to start
job or enable these services you don't
have to go looking for the executables
to start these services so how do you
configure a program or software as a
service say for example you have a
simple Python program it could be a
simple web server that's developed in
Python and the code is available at opt
code my ab dot py you can run this
server with the Python interpreter once
it's running
if you call the local host for port 5000
you see it return hello world which
happens to be the response of the web
server now I want to configure this as a
service now so you want your program to
run as a service so that when you run
the system kuddle start command it
starts and when you run the system
cuddles stop command it stops and
similarly you want to configure your
application to automatically start when
the system boots up and you know even
automatically restart in case the
application crashes how do you do that
as we just saw the system cuddle
command-line utility is used to manage
the system these services so we must
configure our program as a system de
service so how do we do that
a system DS service is configured using
a system D unit file these files may be
located at Etsy system D slash system
path so let's create a unit file at Etsy
system D system path the file must be
named with the name that you eventually
want the service to be known as in this
case we'll name it my app and with an
extension dot service define a section
called
service using the square brackets and
inside the file and provide a directive
named exact start under it this is where
you specify the command that you will be
using to run your application so the
same command that we run here we're
going to put it over here and that's it
that's enough to configure your
application as a service run the system
cuddle daemon reload command to let
system D know that there is a new
service configured and then run the
system cuddle start command and provide
the name of the service in this case my
underscore app let's check the status of
the new service using the system cuddle
status command it lists that the service
is in an active and running state
you can now test by performing a coal
operation on port 5000 of localhost to
stop the application run the system
cuddle stop command okay so we have
configured our application to run as a
service and we are now able to start and
stop it as required so how do we
configure it to automatically run when
the system boots up we configure that in
the unit file and the unit configuration
file has many other options and the
service section is only one of the many
sections another section is the install
section so in this section we basically
need to configure this service to run
after a particular service that runs at
boot up so one way to specify that is
using the wanted by directive we can
configure this service to run after the
multi-user target run level is started
once this is done you can configure the
service to start during boot up using
the system cuddle enable command you can
also provide additional metadata
information about the service such as
description that would allow others to
understand what this service is about
now for that add a new section in the
file called unit and use the description
directive if your application has other
dependencies such as commands or scripts
that are to be run before starting the
application or after starting the
application then add the exact start pre
and exact start post directives and
specify the scripts or commands to be
run if you'd like the application to
automatically restart in case it crashes
specify the restart directive and set
its value to always so let's take an
example of a real software say docker
right well we're not going to talk about
docker itself we have you know multiple
courses on docker where we talk a lot
about docker in this context docker is
just an example of a software so and
it's the same with any software so you
don't really need to know anything about
docker to understand this lecture so
once
Curry's installed docker daemon runs as
a background process that listens for
docker commands when docker is installed
an executable named docker D is made
available on the system at path slash
users slash bin slash docker D this is
configured as a service using the system
unit file at path Lib a system the
system docker dot service now this file
has three sections the unit service and
install section as we just learned and
you can see the description as well as
some of the other details such as link
to documentation etc and the service
section has the command that is run to
start the docker daemon which is
specified under the exec start section
in this section we will learn more about
control based text editors in Linux
earlier in this course we saw the usage
of the cat command to write and redirect
data into a file while this works well
and has its uses it is a very basic form
and offers no additional features and is
not feasible when dealing with adding or
manipulating a large amount of texts or
for writing code in the DevOps and cloud
world you'll be working with a number of
Linux servers and most of the time
you'll be accessing them remotely using
terminal tools and you'll be modifying
content in a number of files
configuration files mostly so getting
the basics of VI editor comes in really
handy in such cases there are a number
of text editors available in Linux and
such as VI vim Nano etc and in this
course we will look at VI editor which
happens to be the most popular one VI
editor comes installed by default with
most operating systems run the VI
command and specify the filename to open
it the terminal opens the file and you
are now inside the VI editor VI editor
has two modes of operation the command
mode and the insert mode when you open
file in VI editor you are by default in
the command mode in this mode you can
issue commands to the editor such as to
copy and paste lines or delete a line or
a word or to navigate between lines etc
but you cannot write contents to the
file to write contents to the file you
must switch to the insert mode to switch
to the insert mode type lower case I
once you are in insert mode you may
modify the file contents as you would
normally to switch back from insert mode
to the command mode press the Escape key
let's see what operations are available
in the command mode you may move around
through the editor using the arrow keys
or the keys kjh l on your keyboard k to
go up edge to left j to down and l to
the right to delete a character press X
typing DD deletes the entire line to
copy a line type YY and to paste it type
in p2 scroll the page up or down press
the ctrl + U or D buttons typing in
colon takes you to the prompt where you
can type in commands to save the changes
made to the file and write the file to
disk use the colon W command you can
optionally specify a file name as well
to discard any unsaved changes made to
the file and quit wim type in : q
command to save changes and quit type in
: WQ command so how do you find stuff
for example I want to find the word off
in this file for this type in the
command slash off when you do that all
occurrences of the word off is
highlighted and the cursor is positioned
at that location to move your cursor to
the rest of the occurrences press the N
key and you can continue to press the N
key to move the cursor to all future
occurrences well
that's it for the basics of VI editor
for now in this section we will talk
about setting up a lab for beginning
your studies on DevOps and cloud
technologies at code cloud we have
embedded labs for our courses and we
provide you a readily available
environment to work on but at times you
may want to set up your own personal
learning environment an environment
where your changes are persistent and an
environment where you can develop your
own custom solutions and this section
will help you create your own lab as
well as troubleshoot and maintain it
which is something that most students
struggle with we will discuss the
different options available to set up a
lab environment such as laptops or cloud
we will discuss using VirtualBox as a
solution to set up labs on your laptop
we will discuss how to deploy multiple
VMs in a VirtualBox environment we will
discuss networking in VirtualBox which
is one of the topics that a lot of our
students have trouble with such as
getting the VMS to talk to each other
accessing the internet from the from the
VMS SSH into to the VMS etc we will also
discuss how to take snapshots to save
the state of VMs and restore those
snapshots we will then discuss how to
automate the deployment of VMs using
vagrant a vagrant is a really neat tool
that can help you set up a local lab
environment very easily and it is I
highly recommend you to learn that and
finally we will also look at some
options available on the cloud to set up
your own lab environment you have two
options one is your laptop either office
or home the second is on the cloud a
private cloud within your organization
or a public cloud provider like Google
AWS or a sure there are many cloud
providers that offer free tier where you
can create VMs and use them for free we
will talk about some of those later for
now let's start with a lab setup on a
home laptop or desktop environment this
could also be an office laptop I
personally prefer a home laptop as I can
do anything with it as I want I don't
need to take approvals or raise requests
to
firewalls or get permission to install
software on it I want to be independent
and do whatever I want to do so you need
such an environment to play around with
and to break and and then fix it back
together and basically do anything that
you want to do with it so what is a home
lab environment and what are the kind of
things that you will be needing it for
while going through DevOps
cloud or IT automation courses you will
often come across a set of tools that
you will need to work with tools such as
kit for source code management build
tools like Jenkins for running bills
programming language frameworks like
Java Python or nodejs they're dependent
libraries and packages web servers like
Apache web server nginx Tomcat servers
or databases like MySQL MongoDB etc or
containerization tools like docker or
kubernetes and automation tools like
ansible chef or puppet as well as cloud
management tools like you know cloud
SDKs or cloud command-line tools and
even different operating systems even
such as Ubuntu cent OS fedora etc now
you can install all of these directly on
your laptop and play around with them
but at some point it's going to start
impacting the performance of your laptop
and you might run into compatibility
related issues different applications
may have a requirement for different
versions of these software's and then
you'll try to uninstall and reinstall
them and soon you'll see yourself in an
installation and cleanup loop and trying
to get it all working and soon you'll
end up reimagining your laptop and
losing all your configurations and all
of the personalization that you did to
your laptop so one way to combat that is
to do everything that you need to do
within a virtual machine on your laptop
so this way if things go south you can
simply delete your virtual machine and
provision anyone or take a backup of
your virtual machine and restore state
from backup we will discuss how
do that later in this section this also
allows you to try different things in
different virtual machines and have
different operating systems on different
virtual machines irrespective of what OS
you are on say you are on a Mac or
Windows you can have one VM with one -
and little bit sent OS you can run
Windows or Linux on Mac or a Windows
server on Linux or a Linux on Windows or
Mac etc and you can have as many systems
as you want as long as you have
sufficient hardware resources now of
course all of all of these tools that
are listed here some of them definitely
need to be on your laptop such as git or
you know the a few other popular tools
that you would use on a day-to-day basis
for development purposes but what I'm
referring to here are more of the tools
like programming language frameworks or
build tools or web servers or databases
etc so what is a software that can help
you create these virtual machines these
virtual machines into which you can you
know that does which we can play around
with or install applications on it's
called as a virtualization software or
hypervisors now you might have heard
about VMware ESX servers or Windows
hyper-v servers that can create virtual
machines these are known as type 1
hypervisor
they're installed directly on bare metal
such as a laptop or server and then the
VMS are created on that now these are
used in enterprises and production
environments where you need to create
and manage large number of virtual
machines and as such these hypervisors
have high resource requirements they
also need to be installed and configured
directly on the laptop and they are
expensive as well a lot of people do use
this for home labs especially if they
have systems with high resources but
that's not what we want here for our
purpose there are other solutions
available that better suit our needs and
are easy to manage and those are type 2
hypervisors there hypervisors that runs
on an existing operating system examples
are
oracle virtualbox and VMware Workstation
these allow you to easily get started
with virtual machines on your laptops
without having to install any other
operating system or reimage your laptop
so going forward when we say a host
operating system we are referring to the
main OS on our laptop and when we talk
about guest operating systems we are
referring to the VMS that are created on
the hypervisors which are on the
operating system and so these are our
topic of interest Oracle VirtualBox and
William ware workstation both of these
are very easy to get started with just
download and install and off you go but
which one among the two Oracle
VirtualBox is a free and open source
tool it can be installed and used to
create virtual machines on Windows Linux
or Mac exactly the same way
it supports backup and recovery with
snapshots and clone features it lets you
run multiple VMs together and also helps
you create separate networks within your
laptop for different groups of VMS we am
or workstation is on the other hand is
not a free software it can only be
installed on Windows or Linux and not
Mac and it supports advanced features
like snapshots and clones there is a
free version of VMware Workstation known
as VMware Player that's available for
Windows and Linux and VMware fusion
which is available for Mac however these
do not have many features that vmware
workstation or VirtualBox supports such
as running multiple VMs at the same time
or taking snapshots or performing you
know advanced networking configurations
so if you ask me considering the cost
benefits and the features Oracle
VirtualBox is my choice for a home lab
environment so Oracle VirtualBox is
supported on Windows Linux Mac or
Solaris platforms visit this link to go
to the downloads page and download the
package for your operating system and
this link gives you the list of
supported operating system versions
with respect to resource requirements
oracle virtualbox can be installed on a
system with an x86 hardware with memory
as small as 512 mb and only consumes
around 30 MB of disk space for itself
however since virtual machines require
resources it's a good idea to have
additional resources on your host system
a lot more actually so a dual-core or
quad-core processor and a memory of at
least 4gb and disk space of at least 100
GB or more will help you set up one or
two small VMs and you can be really
smart in managing resources by
allocating VMs with only sufficient
resources that that it requires and
using lightweight OS images instead of
the full-blown OS images so once it's
installed open up the VirtualBox tool by
starting the executable it should be
available in your application section or
in your program section on Windows to
create a new virtual machine hit the new
button at the top then give your VM a
name and specify the location where you
want the files of the VM to be created
the VM itself and the discs of the VM
are stored as a file on the host
operating system set the type of the OS
to Linux and since the VM that I intend
to create is st. OS machine
I choose Red Hat 64-bit as my OS version
because cent OS is a community fork of
Red Hat Enterprise Linux so they're kind
of the same except that Red Hat
Enterprise Linux has a lot more advanced
packages and and built-in features but
at the core they are the same so from
the list of options available now you
have Linux and debian fedora you don't
see cent OS but instead of that you can
just select Red Hat and then you have
others like open so say 1 2 etc the next
step is assigning memory resources this
may differ between different OSS if your
OS is lightweight you may assign a
smaller amount of memory 1gb is usually
good and
next we select the hard-disk okay here's
where you can create and attach a new
disk to the VM now a new disk means it's
blank and does not have anything on it
it doesn't even have an operating system
on it now creating a new VM is like
buying a new PC or a laptop without an
operating system you decide what CPU
memory and disk configurations are
needed and then you buy the laptop and
get the disks attach the disk to the
machine and then the disk is a blank
disk and there's no operating system on
it so you need to install an operating
system using an OS CD so just like how
you would install an OS on a laptop you
would need to install an OS on a virtual
machine created like this now that's one
approach but there's a better way and
what if the disk you attached already
has an OS on it a pre-configured
pre-built OS that way when the VM is
created we attach the disk which has the
OS on it and then when it boots it's
ready to go you don't have to manually
install the OS so how do we create those
disks and where do we get such disks
from well it so happens that a large
collection of such pre-configured disks
or images as it is called are available
on the Internet and one such website is
OS boxes org they have a list of images
for all kinds of operating systems like
ubuntu debian cent OS fedora etc once an
image is downloaded use that as an
existing virtual hard disk file while
creating the VM and that's it and the VM
is now created now all you need to do is
start the VM by right-clicking and
selecting the normal start option from
the menu in the next lecture we will see
the different ways of connecting to the
VM and working with it and that's one
area a lot of people have problems with
like how do you SSH into the VM how do I
access a service hosted on
um etc and that's what we will cover in
the next lecture in this demo we're
going to see how to set up a lab
environment okay so in my case I have a
Windows system so I will be setting up a
lab environment on my Windows system it
doesn't really matter what operating
system you're on you could follow the
same instructions to set up a lab
environment on Linux or your Mac
operating systems so in our case we're
going to install VirtualBox so go to
virtualbox.org g and in the website you
will have find a link to download the
VirtualBox software in the download page
you will find is links to download
VirtualBox for specific operating
systems in my case i'm in mine is
windows i'm going to click on windows
and i'm going to download the software
once downloaded run the executable and
follow the instructions in the
installation wizard to complete
installation in my case I've already
installed it so I'm just going to cancel
that
after you install open up the Oracle VM
VirtualBox interface and it will look
something like this now the next step is
to deploy virtual machines in order to
do that you can either create a machine
attach a CD drive of an operating system
and follow the instructions to install
the operating system as we are familiar
with however there's also an another
easy way
there are pre-installed pre-configured
operating system images available on the
Internet
we could use those to easily deploy as
many virtual machines as we need for
this if you go to the website OS box's
org you will find a lot of pre-installed
pre-configured images of various
operating systems go to the site and
select the VM images VirtualBox images
link at the top then you will be will
find a list of various different
operating systems from this we will
select st. OS and then it will take us
to the Centaurs page here you can see
information on downloading the Centaurs
image in our case we're downloading the
VirtualBox image for st. OS 7 and we're
downloading the 64-bit portion so
remember to download
that particular version we will then it
is downloaded as a dot 7z file which is
a compressed file so you need a software
to uncompress it like a tar or winzip my
case I'm using the 7-zip software to
extract the contents of the file into a
folder wait for it to finish the
extraction process once finished if you
go into the folder you will see that
there is a folder called 64-bit and
inside that folder you'll find a file
with the extension dot VDI the stands
for virtual disk and that is what we
will use to create a virtual machine
we're now ready to create a new virtual
machine so we go back into the Oracle VM
VirtualBox interface click on new and we
fill in the name and operating system
now I will name the virtual machine that
I'm creating as CentOS - template
because as we discussed we our goal is
to create a template and then use that
template to create as many virtual
machines as I need so I'm going to name
it as centaurs - template I will now
select the type as Linux and the version
since it does not have sent OS listed I
could simply select other now as you can
see another versions there are 32-bit as
well as 64-bit options in our case we
downloaded the center with 64-bit
version so we must select a 64-bit
option now in case you do not see the
64-bit options in this list and that is
most probably because you do not have
the virtualization technology enabled on
your laptop to enable virtualization
technology on your laptop
it is usually under the BIOS settings so
if you simply Google enable
virtualization in BIOS followed by your
laptop model you will see a set of
results it's usually it usually looks
something like this under the BIOS under
the advanced BIOS features you'll have
something called as virtualization
and you must ensure that it is set to
enable state so once you do that restart
your laptop and you will find the 64-bit
option and click Next in the next here
we select a memory size by default it's
set to 512 MB and let's change that to
around 2 GB so we'll set it to 2 2 gigs
in the next step we select the hard disk
that we downloaded so in this case the
default selection is create a virtual
hard disk now but that's not what we
want we already have a prebuilt image of
a hard disk downloaded so we're going to
specify that select the use an existing
virtual hard disk file option and click
on browse and browse to the file that we
downloaded and extracted which is the
centralized 7 file with the VDI
extension click on ok and that creates
the file now before powering on the
template we will go into settings and
make a few more changes good system and
will increase the CPU to around 2 and we
go to network section and we will set
the adapter 1 to bridge network this way
my virtual machine gets an IP address as
well as it can connect to the internet
to download and install packages as
required I will now go ahead and power
on the system
you
okay I'm now at the login prompt select
the default user which is the Oh which
is OS boxes now the password to find out
the password for any images downloaded
from OS boxes org go to the info section
and then you'll see that the user name
is OS boxes and the password is always
boxes dot o-r-g so I'm going to use that
password OS boxes dot part G I will
click on sign-in to log in to this
entire system in this demo we are going
to see how to set up a lab environment
so in our case we're going to install
VirtualBox so go to virtualbox.org G and
in the web site you will have find a
link to download the VirtualBox software
in the download page you will find is
links to download VirtualBox for
specific operating systems I'm going to
download the software once downloaded
run the executable and follow the
instructions in the installation wizard
to complete installation after you
install open up the Oracle VM VirtualBox
interface and it will look something
like this
now the next step is to deploy virtual
machines in order to do that you can
either create a machine attach a CD
drive of an operating system and follow
the instructions to install the
operating system as we are familiar with
however there's also an another easy way
there are pre-installed pre-configured
operating system images available on the
internet we could use those to easily
deploy as many ocean machines as we need
for this if you go to the website OS
boxes org you will find a lot of
pre-installed pre-configured images of
various operating systems go to the site
and select the VM images VirtualBox
images link at the top then you will be
will find a list of various different
operating systems from this we will
select st. OS and then it will take us
to the Centaurs page here you can see
information on downloading the Centaurs
image in our case we're downloading the
VirtualBox image for sent OS 7
we're downloading the 64-bit version so
remember to download that particular
version it is downloaded as a dot 7z
file which is a compressed file so you
need a software to uncompress it wait
for it to finish the extraction process
once finished if you go into the folder
you will see that there is a folder
called 64-bit and inside that folder
you'll find a file with the extension
VDI the stands for virtual disk and that
is what we will use to create a virtual
machine we're now ready to create a new
virtual machine so we go back into the
Oracle VM VirtualBox interface click on
new and we fill in the name and
operating system I will now select the
type as Linux and click Next in the next
here we select a memory size in the next
step we select the hard disk that we
downloaded so in this case the default
selection is create a virtual hard disk
now but that's not what we want we
already have a pre-built image of a hard
disk downloaded so we're going to
specify that select the use an existing
virtual hard disk file option and click
on browse and browse to the file that we
downloaded and extracted which is the
Centaurs 7 file with the VDI
extension click on OK and that creates
the file now before powering on the
template we will go into settings and
make a few more changes
good system and will increase the CPU to
around 2
I will now go ahead and power on the
system
you
in this lecture we will look at how to
connect to the VM we created in the
previous video now some of the most
frequently asked questions about setting
up a local lab environment revolves
around connectivity how do we connect to
the VM and how do we SSH into it why
can't I access the you know something
that's a hosted on the VM such as a web
browser and we'll find answers for these
in this video so on our laptop which we
will call as the host system we have
deployed Oracle VirtualBox
and created a VM having s into s image
which happens to be the same the guest
system I'm using Mac but it works the
same for Windows or Linux now when a VM
is installed and ready you can start the
VM either in a normal mode or a headless
mode now a normal mode gives you a
console to the VM you can see the UI of
the VM as you would see a Linux laptop
Buddha it's like looking at the monitor
of a machine if the image we downloaded
came with a Linux GUI as well then we
can see the GUI on the screen and work
with the VM like working with any other
in a GUI the GUI is okay to explore and
maybe you know play around with
initially but when you get into real
DevOps and cloud and automation tasks it
would be better to have CLI access so I
personally never use the GUI because
it's in fact a bit painful to work with
you know switching between your system
and the VM UI and since it's a VM the
GUI and console may be a bit slow you
can't easily copy and paste stuff from
your hosts to the guest or you know copy
files back and forth you can but it's
just not that easy now eventually you
need a terminal to work with a Linux
system and that is to run commands for
you know installing packages working
with services etc so instead of using
the terminal inside the GUI it is a lot
more convenient to use a terminal on
your host laptop
in the normal mode when the console is
closed the VM must be shut down or
suspended it pops up this message where
it gives you these three options the
first one says save the Machine state
which is suspend and then sent or the
other options are send a shutdown signal
or power of the machine the other option
shown here is the headless start so if
that is selected the VM still starts but
the console window won't be opened the
William can only be accessed remotely
using SSH or remote desktop tools for
Windows the third option is where it can
be started in a normal mode but closing
the console won't require you to suspend
or shut down the VM instead you have you
now have a new option and that says
continue to run in the background so
that just selecting that option simply
causes the console alone and it
continues to keep the VM running in the
background depending on what OS has been
used on the guest system we have
different ways of connecting to it for
example say we had a Windows system to
remotely connect to the Windows system
without using the console you could use
the some kind of remote desktop clients
such as the one provided by Microsoft
now if the guest has a Linux operating
system as it is in case of sent OS we
can connect to it remotely through SSH
using SSH clients like the terminal app
in in Linux or Mac and tools like putty
in Windows although the VMS are within
our laptop think of them as separate
machines connected to the same network
so whatever you need for one system to
connect to another system
you would need that here for this to
work you must have these VMs configured
with IP addresses and the relevant
services must be configured and running
on Windows you need the Remote Desktop
service to be running and on Linux you
need the SSH service to be running so
make sure SSH server is installed and is
in a running State if so you can SSH
into the VM from the host system using
the terminal
on the host and the IP address of the
remote VM but how do you configure SSH
service and IP addresses on the VM if
you can't connect to it on the first
place for that you could use the console
to perform initial configuration it's a
common practice to use the console to
perform initial configurations and then
once SSH is enabled switch over to the
terminal for all future interactions so
if you run into issues connecting to a
VM check to make sure that the VM has an
IP address set and that you are using
the right IP address and that SSH
service on the remote VM is running so
here's a quick example on how to check
or set IP addresses in a centralized
machine run the IP address show command
and it lists all interfaces and IP
addresses assigned to them the first
interface is the loopback interface with
the IP 127 dot 0 dot 0 dot one and the
second interface is e 0 which is the
interface used for connectivity and it
has IP addresses are 192 dot 168 of 1.10
now if the IP address was not set you
can set the IP using the IP address add
command and specify the IP address
followed by the subnet mask and the
device you want to set the IP on which
happens to be e 0 in this case now with
different operating systems the device
names as well as commands may differ so
refer to the operating system
documentation xand and find out the
right relevant way to set IP address and
here's a quick tip on checking the SSH
service the SSH service comes by default
with sent OS image to check if the
daemon is running run the service hisses
HD status command if it's not running
run the service sshd start command to
start it well that's it for now we will
now head over to a demo and see this in
action
and in the upcoming lectures we will
discuss more about networking in
VirtualBox
okay I'm now at the login prompt select
the default user which is the Oh ages OS
boxes now the password to find out the
password for any images downloaded from
OS boxes org go to the info section and
then you'll see that the user name is OS
boxes and the password is always boxes
dot o-r-g so I'm going to use that
password OS boxes stored part G I'll
click on sign in to log in to this
entire system I'll open up a terminal
and type in ifconfig the ifconfig
command tells me the IP address
currently assigned to the virtual
machine as you can see it is one ninety
two dot one sixty eight dot one dot one
one two now I will open up a SSS
terminal to SSH into that virtual
machine and in my case I'm using a
terminal software called as mobile extra
I like to use this this is a free
software that is available you could use
any SSH terminal software you could
simply use putty as well so create a new
SSH session and specify the IP address
which is one ninety two dot one sixty
eight dot one dot one one two and the
username is OS boxes click on ok now
we'll specify the password which is OS
boxes dot o-r-g and M logged in so there
are different ways to connect to a Linux
VM on VirtualBox depending on how you
set up your networking I used two
different approaches while deploying the
VMS in Windows and Mac so I kind of had
two demos there Windows and Mac you
don't have to go through them it's kind
of the same demo the only difference
between the two is that on one I set up
a bridged networking and on the other I
didn't okay so the one on the left as
you see here is the setting on Mac and
on the one on the right is the setting
on
windows on the windows deployment I
added a bridge adapter and on the Mac OS
I didn't I just configured the default
NAT option for the networking adapter
now if you had configured the bridge
adapter as in Windows the VM becomes
part of the external network and it gets
an IP address assigned to it you can
simply SSH to it as you would SSH to
another system in your network in case
of NAT as in the Mac setup it doesn't
connect to the external network and so
does not get an IP address on the
external network that we can use to SSH
to so we will use port forwarding as we
discussed in the previous lecture I also
want to point out that this doesn't have
anything to do with Windows or Mac both
these network configurations can be
configured on either OS and it works the
same I just chose two different options
just to show you the difference between
the two okay so let's proceed with the
connectivity on Mac once the system is
powered on if the console looks too
small you can go to the View menu and
scale visibility to 300% there is a
welcome screen and wizard within the
console so just go through that and
close them
from the applications menu select
terminal will not check the IP address
of the system so we type in IP address
show command to see the IP addresses as
you can see it gets an IP address of
10.0 2.15 now this is a private internal
IP assigned by the NAT router for this
VM so this IP is not reachable from
anywhere else
neither the host or nor any other VMs
created on this network so don't try to
you know ping this IP or SSH to this IP
here from the host you do not be able to
do that if you had multiple VMs
you will see that all VMs configured
with NAT are isolated and they all get
the same IP address assigned and they
cannot reach each other
however with network address translation
they can reach the external world so you
should have internet connectivity if
your host has internet connectivity you
can verify that by trying to ping an
external website like this ok so that
looks good so how do you remotely
connect to this system like if you want
to SSH into this VM to perform you know
to carry out operations to run commands
how do you do that so first verify that
the SSH service is running for this run
the service SSH D status command we see
the status is active now our goal is to
SSH into this VM from a terminal on our
host since it doesn't have an IP address
that we can SSH to we will set up port
forwarding go to the settings menu of
this VM and under the network section
select port forwarding
add a new rule we will forward a port on
our localhost to a port on the VM the
SSH service listens on port 22 on the VM
but we also have an SSH service on our
host that uses port 22 so we cannot
forward 22 on our host to the VM so we
will configure another port say port 22
22 on the host to forward to port 22 on
the VM so we add a rule for that and we
name it SSH port now I could try to SSH
to my local host IP or a loopback IP
address which is 127 dot 0 dot 0 dot 1
and specify port 22 22 and if you'd like
to log in as root user specify the user
name before the IP address and enter the
password OS box's dot org
and you're in well we've now connected
to our VM and we can now run any
commands we'll inspect the release files
under the Etsy directory using the cat
command to verify the version of OS and
as we can see that it's CentOS 7
so we've connected to the right system
okay so that's it for this demo in this
lecture we will look at the various
networking options available within
VirtualBox some of the common issues
that our students face with respect to
VirtualBox is around networking a lot of
our students struggle with understanding
the different kinds of networks such as
NAT bridge and host only and what they
mean and what type of network to be used
when also how do multiple VMs connect
with each other and how to troubleshoot
issues where you can't reach the
internet and that's what we will discuss
in this video so before getting into
networking in VirtualBox
let us first revise some of the basic
networking concepts now computer systems
like our laptops or servers have
different kinds of interfaces or
adapters that are used for connectivity
such as wired Ethernet interfaces to
connect to a LAN network through a hub
or a switch using a cable & wireless
interfaces to connect to the
network through Wi-Fi now irrespective
of how they connect to a network once
they do they get an IP address assigned
either manually or dynamically if there
is a DHCP server in the environment an
IP address is assigned to an interface
in this case we have a laptop that's
connected using an Ethernet cable to a
switch in our home once the connection
is established our laptop gets an IP
address when you run the IP address show
command you see the interface en p0 s3
and it has the IP address 192 dot 168 or
1.5 now say you have another adapter a
Wi-Fi adapter and you attach that to the
same network but this time through Wi-Fi
then that interface gets another IP
address assigned to it and can be seen
in the output of the same command the
same laptop now has two separate IP
addresses on the same network if any
other host were to try to reach our
laptop you know they may do so using any
of these IP addresses so what I'm trying
to say is every system every computer
system has different interfaces and it
can have multiple such interfaces and
adapters to connect to different
networks so it could be the same network
which is which is as it is in this case
but it could be to connect to different
networks and some interfaces have
internet connectivity depending on what
network they're connected to and the
others do not
once a virtual machine is provisioned in
VirtualBox if you go to the settings of
that VM and in the network tab you will
see different networking options to
start with there are four adapters this
means that you can configure your VM to
have up to four network connections
now how you configure those and what do
you connect these adapters to is up to
you by default only the first adapter is
enabled and it is attached to NAT as you
can see there are multiple options
available here nat bridge adapter
host-only adapter being some of them and
we will see what these options
our next so let's start with a simple
example say we have a physical system
like our laptop or a PC and it's
connected to the network with the
address 192 dot 168 of 1.0 so you set an
IP for your PC to one ninety two dot one
sixty eight dot one dot ten and we have
VirtualBox on it say for example a on
VirtualBox we have provisioned multiple
virtual machines so there are four
virtual machines provisioned now how do
these VMs talk to each other how do they
read systems outside of your PC now as
of now these virtual machines are simply
created they don't have any network or
any IP address assigned to them so if
you log into any of these VMs through
their console and try to ping one
another it would fail and it wouldn't be
you wouldn't even know what the IP
address is due to a pain in the first
place so we create a private network
within our PC it's called as a host only
network and has an address 192 dot 168
of Phi dot 0 so we attached the virtual
interfaces of the VMS to this network
now I'll explain how we do that in a bit
but let me first cover the concepts so
once you attach the interfaces of the
virtual interfaces of the VMS to this
network they all get an IP address in
the 192 dot 168 our Fido series in that
range so one system gets 192 168 5.2
another one gets 503 504 and 505 our PC
is a part of the network so a virtual
interface is created on our PC and
connected to the same network and it
gets an IP one ninety two dot one sixty
eight dot 5.1 so all the VMS and pc
itself are now part of a virtual private
host only network the reason it's called
host only is because the connectivity is
contained within this host all the
william's can reach each other but they
cannot reach the outside wall
nor can anyone outside this host reach
these virtual machines they're all on a
private internal host only network so
how do you create this host only network
and how do you attach reams to this to
create this host only network on
VirtualBox on Mac go to file and then
host network manager you'll have a
similar option available for Windows and
Linux as well so just find out where
that is once you go into the host
network manager inside the host network
manager create a new network by clicking
on the create button this creates an
internal virtual network in our laptop
and creates an interface by the name
VBox net 0 and assigns our laptop the
first IP address on this interface if
you run the ifconfig command you see the
two IP addresses assigned to my laptop
the 102 168 1 dot 10 on the internal
adapter and 192 168 5.1 on the VBox net
0 adapter so that's the network the
first network created by VirtualBox and
you can create multiple such hosts only
networks within mercial box so now that
we have created the network to attach a
VM to this network go to the settings
page of a VM and under network select
the adapter and select attach to
host-only adapter and select the new
network that we created so do that on
each VM and since this host only network
also has DHCP and enabled the Williams
I'll get an IP assigned automatically ok
so that was one scenario let's look at
another option so say we have another
physical machine in the network so just
building off of that previous example
where we have on one side we have our
host on network and the and the VMS
inside it but we also have another host
that's attached to this particular
network and it has an IP 192 168 1 dot
11 the PC has some kind of service
running on it such as let's say a
database
instance for example and our VMs on the
first PC would like to access this
particular database now in the current
setup with the host only network the VMS
are not going to be able to do that is
because they are on a host only network
and they cannot really reach outside of
that host so for this we introduce a nat
network so instead of creating a host
only network we create a NAT Network the
Nats network is similar to the host only
network where as in we create a private
network within the physical system and
we attach all the VMS to it and they all
get an IP address but this time these
VMs can access the outside world the VMS
can now access the database using its IP
address now for every packet that is
sent from the VM to the database the NAT
engine which sits on the on our host is
going to replace the source IP with its
own IP address so that when the database
receives a request is going to think
that it's all coming from the first PC
it is unaware of the VMS that are
present on the first pc so it processes
the request and sends back the data to
the first PC the NAT engine on receiving
the response intercepts the packet and
changes the address back to the original
VMS IP and forwards it back to the vm so
that's what's called address translation
and that's why network address
translation when a request is sent the
network the from address is actually
translated to the host address and then
the request goes and then when the
response is received the the to address
is changed back to the original address
of the VM that in fact send the request
so with this setup the VMS within can
access the outside world but remember
the outside world is still unaware of
the VMS that exists within the system so
no systems from the outside world can
access the VMS inside
so how do you do that to create an ad
network go to the VirtualBox preferences
page and select Network and there you
will find nat networks click the plus
button and create a new NAT network once
created to attach a VM to this NAT
network go to the VM settings and under
network attach the adapter to Matt's
network now note that it is different
from NAT so NAT and net network are
different and then select the name of
the net network and that's all so what
is NAT and NAT network what is the
difference between NAT and network and
NAT NAT is the default setting of a VM
on VirtualBox it works similar to NAT
network as in the VMS can reach the
external world and you know users net
and network address translation so that
when workers go out they go out with the
address of the house and when responses
are received the address is replaced by
the virtual network within that VM
however you don't have that internal
network here so as such the beams are
not able to reach each other so each VM
is isolated they cannot talk to each
other but they can talk to external
systems through the host so each in this
case each VM kind of gets its own NAT
router whereas in the earlier case there
was a net network and there was a single
NAT router that there works for all VMs
in this case there's more isolation
between the VMS within the host so that
was about NAT now let's look at another
scenario where an external host requires
access to the internal VMs so if you've
been talking about internal VMS trying
to access external services but now
let's see what happens if we want
external services or external VMS to
access internal VMS services or services
running on these internal VMS so say for
example there's a web application
running on one of these VMs and there
are other systems that are on our
network list such as you know lat
and these laptops want to access the web
server that's running inside one of
these VMs so let's look at another kind
of network known as a bridge network the
bridge network acts as an extension of
the LAN network so you don't really have
to create a bridge Network like how we
created the host only network or the net
network before the bridge network is
always there so you just have to connect
to it
so once the VMs connect to this network
this time they get an IP address in the
same IP range as that of the external
LAN network so they're assigned IPs in
the range 192 168 1 dot series and it is
as though they are all part of the same
external network any device on the
network can see them as just another
virtual machine on the network so even
though they are within the the first
host there in fact it is as if they are
all part of the same network because the
host also gets an IP address am in the
range 192 168 1.10 and the VMS within
the host also get an IP address in the
same range 1 dot 1213 so it's as if
they're all part of the same network but
in fact these VMs are inside this host
so since they are all part of the same
network through the bridge network these
laptops can access any services that are
that are run on these VMs so that's
about bridge network ok so we've talked
about the three kinds of network host
only and NAT and Britten
let's now talk about Internet
connectivity in each of these cases in
case of a net setup whether it's a NAT
network or just NAT we learned that
internal VMs can reach external network
through network address translation so
VM is configured with a NAT interface
can reach internet as long as the host
VM has Internet connectivity you don't
really need em to do anything else
the bridged option as we know is a next
of the external network so it makes the
VM as another host on the network so
just like all hosts on a network the VM
should be able to reach the internet
easily so there's nothing really
required over there - however in case of
a host only network the VMS are on an
internal private network all william's
attached to that internal network can
see each other but they can't connect to
any systems outside of the host machine
the host machine is connected to two
networks the internal host only network
where the we'ums are there and the
external network that has internet
connectivity and that has connectivity
the rest of the network so now we can
enable the host machine to forward
traffic from the internal network to the
external Network now for this you must
enable IP forwarding on the host VM so
this is by default disabled on our
laptops most laptops have that that
functionality so enabling the IP
forwarding feature essentially makes our
laptop a router so a router that can
route traffic one from one network to
another now if you think about it you
don't really have to do that and if all
you need is to establish internet
connectivity for the VMS there are other
ways to do that such as by adding an
additional adapter to these VMs just as
we learned earlier that there are each
of these has four adapters so you can
configure a second adapter and attach it
to net and that way through those
adapters those VMs will have internet
connectivity so that's just another
additional option yeah so this here's
what I was talking about so Holly we
said that there of each VM can have four
adapter so you can configure the second
adapter to be attached to net so now
when you run into connectivity issues
you know where to look at and you know
that you should be looking at the number
of interfaces that are configured on the
VM look at what type of network they are
attached to check if those interfaces
have IP addresses assigned and you
should be able to get a fair idea
you aren't able to reach the internet
now before I let you go one more thing
that's worth mentioning is about port
forwarding so a lecture about worship
box networking is incomplete without
discussing about port forwarding so
let's look at what that is let's look at
a simple scenario where we have a single
VM configured with NAT the the default
option port forwarding allows us to map
a port on the host to a port on the
guest
for example 480 on the host could be
mapped to port 80 on the guest so that
any traffic that comes in on port 80 on
the host is forwarded to port 80 on the
guest now maybe the guest is running a
web server and it's since it's an ad set
up as we discussed before external hosts
can't reach the VM so configuring a port
forward can help the web server receive
requests from external hosts even though
it's in the net set up because the port
forwarding forwards traffic from the
port on the host to the port on the
guest now it need not be the same port
either you can map port 8080 to port
5000 on the VM earlier we discussed that
to SSH into the VM we assign an IP
address and then use that IP address to
SSH from the host to the guest another
way to do that is if you don't know the
IP address of the VM and you can map
port 22
of the guest which is the port used to
establish SSH connection to another port
say 2 - 2 - on the host then you can
simply SSH to the loopback IP address of
the host and port 22 22 and that will in
fact forward those requests to port 22
on the VM and you should be able to SSH
into that so this way you can have
multiple VMs and multiple different
services running on them and you can map
those services
to ports on the host
now this is done under the VM network
settings and by going into the portal
forwarding options here you can see the
different rules to map host port to
guest port as well as specify the
protocols that are used let us now look
at deploying multiple VMs on VirtualBox
and configuring networking between them
we will also look at some cloning and
snapshot functionalities one way to
create multiple VMs is to simply clone
an existing VM so if you plan to create
multiple VMs then it's good to plan
ahead so that you could first create a
template VM and then just create
multiple clones from it to create a
clone for an existing VM right-click the
VM and select the clone option note that
for this option to appear the VM must be
powered off then give the new VM a name
I'll limit VM to and then select the
type of clone so there are two types of
clones a full clone and a linked clone a
full clone creates a full copy of the
disk used by the existing VM consuming
equal amount of new space a linked clone
uses the disk of the existing VM and
only consumes space for the changes made
in the new VM the only concern is when
you plan to move a VM from one system to
another in case of the linked clone
you'll have to copy the disk of the
original VM as well or in case you
decide to delete the original VM you
will run into issues as the linked clone
has a dependency on it so if you don't
plan to copy your VMs then link clone is
a good option as it consumes less space
on your on your laptop okay so I'll just
select linked clone and continue with it
and create the VM so we now have two VMs
before turning and them on let us make
some changes so we want the two VMs to
be able to reach each other so they both
must be part of the same network as per
the current setting they are configured
with
that and so they are isolated from each
other we also want the VMS to be able to
reach the Internet as we plan to install
software on them so we will leave
adapter one with NAT and that's for the
internet and we will configure a second
adapter to connect to a host network for
that we must first create the host
network so go to file and select host
network manager our windows systems
should also have this option once it's
open create a new network I already have
a network in this case and I'll add a
new network it's named V box net one and
as you can see it has an IP address
range one ninety two dot one sixty eight
dot 57 dot one if you'd like the VMS to
get an IP address assigned to them
automatically then check this box and
then click close then go to the VMS
network settings and set the second
adapter to connect to host only network
and choose the newly created network do
that for both VMS also note that if your
system is low on resources
feel free to reduce the CPU and memory
on these VMs as necessary then power on
the VMS and wait for them to boot up
once they are up login using the OS
boxes dot org user account I had created
a user account named Matthew on one
system that's why you see that there you
can also see that on the other system
and that's because when we cloned it all
the settings get cloned as well
now once logged in open up the terminal
and inspect the IP addresses here you
see the new interface that was created
to connect to the new host only network
it's named en p0 s8 the IP address that
got assigned automatically is one ninety
two dot one sixty eight dot 57 dot three
let us now check on the second system
the second system gets IP one ninety two
dot one sixty eight dot 57.4 and
remember we said that our host is also a
part of the network so our host also
gets an IP address of 192 dot 168 or 57
dot one on the network now they all can
reach each other through these IP
addresses we can now SSH to these VMS
using these IP addresses we don't really
need that port forwarding rule we
configured in the previous demo anymore
so SSH and use the root password and I
will use another terminal to SSH to the
other VM
we will also test Internet connectivity
since we have the first adapter
configured for NAT we have Internet
connectivity through that and we see
that successful now just to test and
show you the difference will change the
first adapter to use the other host
network we had instead of the NAT
configuration now when we check the IP
address we see that it now has another
IP on the first interface which earlier
was configured with NAT and if we try to
reach internet now it is not possible so
remember that depending on your
requirements you must set up your
networking configurations if you simply
want the VM to have internet
connectivity then set it to NAT each VM
is isolated if you'd like multiple VMs
to talk to each other and have internet
connectivity choose Nats Network
if you want multiple VMs to reach each
other but no internet connectivity
choose host network in this case your
host will also be part of the same
network and can reach the VMS without
any port forwarding if you'd like the
benefits of multiple networking options
then you can have both of these on a
single VM as we did in this demo so have
one adapter configured to host Network
and the other adapter with NAT now none
of these options really make your VMs
visible to the external network so your
VMs are essentially hidden if you'd like
all of these and also have your VMs
visible on the external Network then
choose the bridged option let us now
look at the snapshot feature with the
snapshot feature you can create a
snapshot or backup of your VMs state at
a particular point in
time and then restored to that backup at
a later point in time let's just pick
the first VM for this demo say we have
an application or a file created in a
directory for example we create a
directory slash opt slash app and under
that we create a file named example dot
TX with the contents an example file so
that's the current good state let us now
take a snapshot so click on this option
on the VM and under that select
snapshots there should be a similar
option for that on other platforms as
well you know in Windows and Linux so
try to find that out here you can see
the current state click on the take
button to create a snapshot we will name
it the good state and provide a
description you can now see a good state
and snapshot created here now we're
going to simulate a failure we will echo
some junk data to the file to simulate
some kind of a corruption ok now that we
have messed up our system and lost the
original contents of the file how do we
restore it go to the snapshots window
and right-click the snapshot named good
state and select the restore option now
the restore option is grayed out because
the VM is still up so let's first shut
it down
now the restored option is available
click on it to restore stapes the
snapshot once restored start the VM we
again connect to it and if you go to the
opt app path you see the example dot txt
file and if you look into its contents
you see that it has a write contents
great
so this functionality is especially
useful when you are testing different
software and functionalities on VMs for
example before making a major change to
your vm such as upgrading the version of
software or packages you could take a
snapshot of the working state to get
back to in the future you can also clone
a new vm from the snapshot say you made
a lot of changes and something went
wrong and you're not sure what that is
and if you'd like to create a new vm
from the previous snapshot that's
possible too so right click the code
snapshot and choose clone and then
follow the same process we followed
earlier to create a new vm from that
clone let us now get introduced to the
basics of vagrant in the previous videos
and demos we looked at how to deploy a
VM on VirtualBox we followed this
process of first downloading the image
from the OS boxes dot org website and
then we created a new VM we then
configured networking such as you know
creating post networks and then we went
into the settings of each VM and
configure the interfaces to use those
correct networking settings and then we
also configured port forwarding and
finally you know booted up the VM we
then repeated these tasks for every VM
that we wish to create vagrant helps us
automate all of these tasks and do all
of these with a single vagrant up
command that way you don't have to go
searching for images of operating
systems or download them or create
networks or configure port forwarding
manually
Begaren does all of that automatically
so vagrant is especially useful when you
have complex systems involving multiple
VMs and if you plan to deploy and manage
the entire setup together to get started
visit vagrant comm and click on the
download option and then download and
install the appropriate version for your
OS once installed run the vagrant in its
command and specify the name of the Box
you'd like to deploy I'd like to deploy
a CentOS 7 box so what is a box a box is
a vagrant term and refers to a packaged
format of a vagrant environment it
contains an OS image as well as scripts
required to configure the environment
you can find a list of all publicly
available vagrant boxes at vagrant cloud
by visiting app vagrant opcom slash
boxes search and find the box of your
choice
running the vagrant init command
initializes the vagrant box in the
current directory and creates a vagrant
file the vagrant file has instructions
on customizing your box we will look at
that in a bit
to start the vagrant box run the vagrant
up command and when this is done vagrant
downloads the image required to create
the VM it then creates the VM gives it a
random name and configures any settings
such as port forwarding or anything like
that and waits for it to be ready
running the vagrant command without any
options lists all available commands you
can see the vagrant box command used to
manage installation and removal of boxes
we just saw the init and up command that
initializes a box and brings up the VM
you may use the suspend command to
suspend a VM the resume command to
resume a VM and the halt command to stop
the VM the destroy command to stop and
the VM and the status command to get the
status of a VM
if the vagrant file is changed use the
reload command to reload the VM you can
also take and restore nap shots using
the vagrant snapshot command you could
SSH into the VM by simply running the
vagrant SSH command vagrant will
identify the port configured for port
forwarding and use that to SSH vagrant
also sets up SSH key based
authentication so it uses that as well
let's take a look at the background file
a vagrant file starts with a
configuration block within the vagrant
configuration block the image used by
the box is specified in this case it
happens to be CentOS class 7 this is all
there is configured in the default
vagrant file if you'd like to customize
this VM this is where you would do it
and then you can share this file with
others and the VM will boot up the same
way in exactly the same way with the
same configurations for everyone for
example you could configure port
forwarding here and say port 8080 on the
host will be forwarded to port 80 on the
guest or you could configure a directory
to sync between the host and the VM that
way you can easily move files from your
host machine to the VM if you'd like to
configure the CPU and memory settings on
the VM then you could do that within the
provider VirtualBox block like this you
can also configure a simple shell script
to run at boot up using the shell
provision block like this so when you
run the vagrant up command now
background provisions a VM following the
specifications given in this vagrant
file and also runs the shell script
given here you may also include multiple
VMs in this this approach can help you
automate the deployment of complex
environments on your laptops
such as small clusters of popular
systems there are
that have automated clusters and such as
kubernetes clusters which has multiple
VMs VirtualBox
is just one provider among the many
supported by vagrant you can also use
vagrant in a VMware environment such as
VMware Workstation or VMware fusion or
in a Microsoft hyper-v environment as
well so I'd highly recommend you to
check out background a and get
comfortable with it this will help you
easily create and deploy virtual machine
or local lab environments as well as
save all the work that you did under
your configurations in a vagrant file
that way in the future you can just if
you'd like to deploy the same kind of
lab environment all you need to do is
run a background up command and then you
can share that wagger and file your
custom file with others in the community
and help others benefit from that as
well let's take a quick demo of vagrant
to download an install vagrant go to
vagrant opcom then go to the downloads
page and select the right version for
your OS I'm on Mac so I'm going to
select Mac OS and this works the same on
all operating systems so you can follow
the same instructions that I'm following
in this demo once the executable is
downloaded install it on your system
once installed the command vagrant
should be available on your system let
us now open up a terminal and create a
directory for vagrant where we will
store all our vagrant configurations
within CD into that directory and we are
now ready to deploy a VM using vagrant
remember you must have the virtual
machine provider which in this case is
VirtualBox already installed on the
system so I already have that it could
also be VMware Workstation or fusion as
well so whatever it is that you plan to
use remember it must exist on the system
before you act
try to bring up a VM using vagrant now
if it's anything other than VirtualBox
then when you run the vagrant up command
you must also specify that provider
using the provider option now we need to
find vagrant boxes to deploy searching
for vagrant boxes in google will land
you on the vagrant cloud page and here
you can search for various boxes for
different operating systems and
solutions I'll go with CentOS 7 select
that in that CentOS 7 page we see a
template for the vagrant file we could
copy this and create a vagrant file by
ourself manually or if we want vagrant
to create that file for us I go to the
new tab and copy the command the command
is a vagrant in it and followed by the
name CentOS 7 all this command does is
create a vagrant file with the image set
to CentOS 7 if you see the contents of
the vagrant file we see that it is
really just a template with all the
options commented out any line that
begins with a hash is commented out the
only line set is the line with the box
name
running the vagrant up command now
downloads the image and then creates a
VirtualBox VM with it
if you open what
you can see the VM being created it
takes a while for it to boot up so give
it some time and once it's booted up we
see the machine booted and the ready
message okay now when you run this
vagrant up command and if you were using
an environment other than VirtualBox
then this is where you must also specify
the provider using the provider option
we can now SSH into the VM using the
vagrant SSH command so even if you are
on a Windows environment you don't
really need another SSH terminal tool or
putty or anything
this command just works it also takes
care of authenticating you into the VM
using SSH keys we are now in and we can
test the version by viewing the Etsy
release files I check the status of the
VM using the vagrant status command we
see it's in a running state to shutdown
run the vagrant halt command we now see
the status is powered off
vagrant file and make some changes if
you go all the way to the bottom we see
the VMS resource settings like memory
and configuration it's currently
commented out if you look at these
settings of the VM we see that it has
512 MB of RAM and 1 v CPU local
resources can increase boot time for the
VM so we'll increase the resources for
the VM from the vagrant file so let's
uncomment the memory specification as
well as the starting and ending of that
block now we will leave the memory to
1gb to provide CPU configuration use the
V B dot CPUs property and we set it to 2
V CPUs we can also rename the VM here
not sure if you notice but the VM has a
random name assigned to it and all of
these settings can be found in the
vagrant documentation page we save that
file and every time you modify the
vagrant file for the changes to take
effect you must run the vagrant reload
command we wait for it to boot up and we
can see that the vm name is already
updated to the name we specified
go into settings and we see the memory
and CPU are set correctly as well at
times when you boot up VMs using the
vagrant up command you might see an
error like this
it's a timeout error what's happening
here is that vagrant starts the VM and
waits for it to boot up completely
however the VM took more time to boot
than vagrant expected this could be
because the VM is configured with very
few resources and it takes a long time
for the VM to load the VM may end up
booting properly eventually and then you
should be able to access the VM as you
would normally but in case you are not
sure and you think it's stuck power of
the VM using the vagrant halt command
and then go to the
file and you can increase the timeout by
adding a property config dot VM dot boot
timeout like this
you
reloading the vagrant file restarts the
VM and the next time vagrant waits
longer before throwing an error message
well that's a quick introduction to
vagrant and I hope it will help you set
up labs quickly if you'd like to learn
more about vagrant please let us know
and we can probably create a separate
course just for vagrant because there
are so many things that you can do with
vagrant in configure multiple VMs you
can configure scripts as we saw in the
lecture so it's a very neat tool to
really set up a custom lab environment
and then save that configuration so that
you can share it with others in this
video we get introduced to DNS in Linux
for the absolute beginners we will
discuss the basic concepts and view some
commands that will help us explore DNS
configuration on hosts specifically
Linux host at the end of this section
you will go through a practice test
where you're given a set of challenges
related to B and s and are asked to
solve them on a live practical hands-on
lab environment right in your browser we
have two computers a and B both part of
the same network and they've been
assigned with IP addresses 192 168 1.10
and 1.11 you're able to ping one
computer from the other using the other
computer's IP address you know that
system B has database services on them
so instead of having to remember the IP
address of the system B you decide to
give it a name DB going forward you
would like to ping system B using the
name DB
instead of its IP address if you try to
ping DB now you would see that host a is
unaware of a host named DB so how do you
fix that basically you want to tell
system a that system be a type e address
192 168 1 dot 11 has a name DB you want
to tell system a that when I say DB I
mean the IP 192 168 1 dot 11 you can do
that by adding an entry into the SC host
file on system a mention the IP address
and the name you want your house to see
system B as with all system a
the IP at 192 168 1.11 is a host named
DB pings to DB now gets sent to the
correct IP nar successful now there is
an important point to note here with old
system a that the IP at 192 168 1.11 is
a host named DB host a takes that for
granted whatever we put in the HC host
file is the source of truth for host a
but that need not be the truth host a
does not check to make sure if system
B's actual name is DB for instance
running a hostname command on system B
reveals that it is named host to but
host it doesn't care it goes by what's
in the host file you can even
full-system a to believing that system B
is Google just add an entry into the
host file with an IP mapping to
www.google.com then ping Google and you
will get a response from system B so we
have two names pointing to the same
system one s DB and another as Google
and we can use either names to read
system B we can have as many names as
you want for as many servers as you want
in the Etsy host file every time we
reference another host by its name from
host a through a ping command or SSH
command or through any of the
applications or tools within this system
it looks into its Etsy host file to find
out the IP address of that host
translating host name to IP address this
way is known as name resolution within a
small network of few systems you can
easily get away with the entries in the
SC host file on each system I specify
which are the other systems in the
environment and that's how it was done
in the past until the environment grew
and these files got filled with too many
entries and managing this became too
hard if one of the server's IP changed
you would need to modify the entries in
all of these hosts and that's where we
decided to move all these entries into a
single server who will manage it
centrally we call that
our DNS server and then we point all
hosts to look up that server if they
need to resolve the host name to an IP
address instead of its own Etsy host
files so how do we do that how do we
point our host to a DNS server our DNS
server has the IP 192 once they see it
100 every host has a DNS resolution
configuration file at Etsy resolve cons
you add an entry into it specifying the
address of the DNS server we say name
server and point it to 192 dot 168 100
and that should be it once this is
configured on all of your hosts every
time a host comes up across a host name
that it does not know about it looks it
up from the DNS server if the IP of any
of the hosts was to change simply update
the DNS server and all hosts should
resolve the new IP address going forward
you no longer need any entries in the SC
host file in any of the hosts but that
does not mean you can't have entries in
host file you still can for example say
you were to provision a test server for
your own needs
you don't think others would need to
resolve the server by its name so it
need not be added to the DNS server in
that case you can add an entry into your
hosts at-sea host file to resolve this
server you can now resolve the server
however no other system will be able to
do that so a system is able to use host
name to IP mapping from the Etsy host
file locally as well as from a remote
DNS server what if you have an entry in
both places one in your Etsy host file
and another in DNS I have an entry in my
local file set to 100 to 168 1.1 1 5 and
someone added an entry for the same host
to 192 168 1.11 6 on the dns server in
that case the host first looks in the
local Etsy host file and then looks at
the name server so if it finds the entry
in the local Etsy host file it uses that
if not it looks for that host in the DNS
server but that
can be changed the order is defined by
an entry in the file at C NS which calms
the line with the hosts entry as you can
see the order is first files and then
followed by DNS files refers to Etsy
host file and DNS refers to the DNS
server so for every host name the hosts
first looks into the Etsy host file and
if it cannot find it there it then looks
at the DNS server this order can be
modified by editing this entry in the
file as per this order our host would
resolve the test server to 192 168 1.11
5 what if we try to ping a server that
is not in either list for example I try
and ping delete wwe.com I don't have
facebook.com in my Etsy host file and
and I don't have it in my DNS server
either so in that case it will fail you
can add another entry into your other
resolve that confiar to point to a name
server that knows Facebook for example
8.8.8.8 is a common well known public
name server available on the Internet
hosted by Google that knows about all
the websites on the Internet you can
have multiple name servers like this
configured on your host but then you
will have to configure that on all your
host in their network you already have a
name server within your network
configured on all the hosts so in that
case you can configure the DNS server
itself to forward any unknown host names
to the public name server on the
Internet
you should now be able to ping external
sites such as Facebook calm until now we
have been just trying to reach systems
with their names like web DB NFS etc but
we just try to ping Facebook at
www.facebook.com/babelsub
and calm at the end it's called a domain
name and it is how IP is translated to
names that we can remember on the public
internet just like how we did for our
hosts now the reason they are in this
format separated by dots is to group
like things together the last portion of
the domain name the dot-com stats edu or
etc are the top-level domains they
represent the intent of the website comp
for commercial or general
dotnet for network dot edu for
educational organizations and dot org
for nonprofit organizations let's look
at one in particular in Google's case
the dot is the route that's where
everything starts com is a top-level
domain Google is the domain name
assigned to Google and www is a
subdomain the subdomains help in further
grouping things together under Google
for example Google's map service is
available at maps.google.com
so Maps is a subdomain Google's storage
service is available at drive.google.com
mobile apps are available at App Store
google.com Google's email service are
available at mail.google.com you can
further divide each of these into as
many subdomains based on your needs so
you begin to see a tree structure
forming when you try to reach any of
these domain names say apps Google come
from within your organization your
request first hits your organization's
internal DNS server it doesn't know who
apps or Google is so it forwards your
request to the internet on the internet
the IP address of the server serving App
Store Google com may be resolved with
the help of multiple DNS servers a root
DNS server looks at your request and
points you to a DNS server serving comps
a.com DNS server looks at your request
and forwards you to Google and Google's
tienen server provides you the IP of the
server serving the apps applications in
order to speed up all future results
your organization's DNS server may
choose to cache this IP for a period of
time typically a few seconds up to few
minutes that way it doesn't have to go
through the whole process again each
time so that was out in the public what
about your organization your
organization can have a similar
structure to for example your
organization could be called as my
computer come and have multiple
subdomains for each purpose the www for
external facing website mailed out my
company intercom for accessing your
organization's mail drive for accessing
storage
paid or company intercom for accessing
the payroll application HR for accessing
HR application etc all of these are
configured in your organization's
internal DNS server the reason we
discussed all of this is to understand
another entry in the Etsy result of con
file remember this is the file where we
configure the DNS server to be used for
our hosts with that we were able to
resolve servers in your organization
with just their names like web we have
now introduced more standard domain
names like web dot my company comm or D
beat up my company.com etc now when you
ping web you can no longer get a
response of course this is because we
are trying to ping web but there is no
record for by the name web on my DNS
server instead it is web dot my company
comm so you have to use web dot my
company dot-com
now I can understand if someone outside
our company wants to access our web
server he would have to use web got my
company dot-com
but within our company your own company
you want to simply address the web
server by its first name web just like
how he utters other members in your
family simply by their first names which
is not the case when someone outside
your family addresses them using their
full names so what do you do to
configure web to resolve my web dot my
company comm you want to say when I say
web I mean web dot my company comm for
that you make an entry into your hosts
Etsy resolved or con file called search
and specify the domain name you want to
append next time you try to ping web you
will see it actually tries web dot my
company comm now your host is
intelligent enough to exclude the search
domain if you specified a domain in your
query like this you may also provide
additional search domains like this so
it would mean when I say web I mean web
dot my company comm or web dot prod dot
my company com so your host will try
searching all of these domain names when
you look for a host name finally a word
about a record types so how are the
records stored in the DNS server we know
that it stores IP - host names that's
known as
Ayer records storing ipv6 to hostnames
is known as quad a records mapping one
name to another name is called cname
records for example you may have
multiple aliases for the same
application like a food delivery service
may also be reached at eat or hungry
that's where a cname record is used name
to name mapping there are many more but
that's what we're going to look at for
now now ping may not always be the right
tool to test DNS reservation there are a
few other tools as well such as nslookup
we can use nslookup to query a hostname
from a DNS server but remember in this
lookup does not consider the entries in
the local Etsy host file so if you add
an entry into the local Etsy host file
for your web application and if you try
to do an NS lookup for that web
application it is not going to find it
the entry for your web application has
to be present in your DNS server
nslookup only queries the DNS server the
same goes with dig dig is another useful
tool to test the NS name resolution it
returns more details in a similar form
as is stored on the server in the
upcoming practice exercises section you
will practice viewing configuring and
troubleshooting DNS in a lab environment
on actual systems through some fun and
challenging exercises in this series of
lectures we get our networking basics
right we look at basic networking
concepts like switching routing gateways
etc we then understand DNS we look at
how to configure DNS settings on a Linux
system so let's get started
so what is a network
we have two computers a and B laptops
desktops VMs on the cloud wherever
how does system a reach B we connect
them to a switch and the switch creates
and network containing the two systems
to connect them to a switch we need an
interface on each host physic
or virtual depending on the host to see
the interfaces for the host we use the
IP link command in this case we look at
the interface named e0 that we will be
using to connect to the switch let's
assume it's a network with the address
192 dot 168 or 1.0 we then assign the
systems with IP addresses on the same
network for this we use the command IP
addr once the links are up and the IP
addresses are assigned the computers can
now communicate with each other through
the switch the switch can only enable
communication within an Network which
means it can receive packets from a host
on the network and deliver it to other
systems within the same network say we
have another network containing systems
C and D at address 192 dot 168 2.0 the
systems have IP address 192 168 2 or 10
and 2 dot 11 respectively how does a
system in one network reach a system in
the other
how does system be with the IP 192 168 1
dot 11 reads system C with the IP 2.10
on the other network that's where a
router comes in a router helps connect
to networks together it is an
intelligent device so think of it as
another server with many network ports
since it connects to the two separate
networks it gets to IPS assigned one on
each network in the first network we
assign it an IP address one of you wants
to steal one dot one and in the second
we assign it an IP 2.1 now we have a
router connected to the two networks
that can enable communication between
them when system b tries to send a
packet to system see how does it know
where the router is on the network to
send the packet through the router is
just another device on the network
there could be many other such devices
that's where we configure the systems
with a gateway or erupted if the network
was a room the Gateway is a door to the
outside world to the other networks or
to the Internet the systems need to know
where that door is to go through that to
see the existing routing configuration
on a system run the route command it
displays the colonel's routing table and
within that as you can see there are no
routing configurations as of now so in
this condition your system B will not be
able to read system C it can only reach
other systems within the same network in
the range 192 dot 168 1.0 to configure a
gateway on system B to reach the
system's on network 2.0 run the IP route
and command and specify that you can
reach the 182 dot one sixty eight dot
2.0 network through the door or Gateway
at one eighty two dot one sixty eight
dot one dot one running the route
command again shows that we have a wrote
added to reach the 182 168 or 0 series
network through the router now remember
this has to be configured on all the
systems for example if the system C is
to send a packet to system B then you
need to add a route on system C's
routing table to access the network at
1.0 through the router configured with
the IP address 2.1 now suppose these
systems need access to the Internet
say they need access to Google at 172
dot 217 to $104 0 network on the
internet so you connect the router to
the Internet and then add a new route in
your routing table to route all traffic
to the network 170 2.2 17.1 94 through
your router there are so many different
sites on different networks on the
internet instead of adding a routing
table entry for the same routers IP
address
for each of those networks you can
simply say for any network that you
don't know a route to use this router as
the default gateway this way any request
to any network outside of your existing
network goes to this particular router
so in a simple setup like this all you
need is a single routing table entry
with the default gateway set to the
routers IP address remember instead of
the word default
you could also say 0.0 0.0 it means any
IP destination both of these lines mean
the same thing in 0.000 entry in the
Gateway field indicates that you don't
need a gateway for example in this case
for system C to access any devices in
the 192 168 2.0 Network it doesn't need
a gateway because it is in its own
network but say you have multiple
routers in your network one for the
internet another for the internal
private network then you will need to
have two separate entries for each
network one entry for the internal
private network and another entry with
the default gateway for all other
networks including public networks so if
you're having issues raising internet
from your systems this routing table and
the default gateway configuration is a
good place to start let us now look at
how we can set up a linux host as a
router let's start with a simple setup I
have three hosts a B and C a and B are
connected to a network 192 168 1 and B
and C to another 1 192 168 dot 2 so host
B is connected to both the networks
using two interfaces it's 0 and it 1a
has IP 182 168 1.5 C has 180 to 160 of
2.5 and B has an IP on both the networks
1.6 and 2.6 how do we get a to talk to C
but basically if I try to ping 2.5 from
a it would say
to work is unreachable and by now we
know why that is host a has no idea how
to reach a network at 192 dot 168 got to
we need to tell host a that the door or
gateway to network to is through host B
and we do that by adding a routing table
entry we add a route to access network
one ninety two dot one sixty eight dot
two while the gateway 192 168 1.6 if the
packets were to get through to host c
host c will have to send back responses
to host a when host c tries to reach
host a at 192 168 1 network it would
face the same issue so we need to let
host c know that it can reach host a
through host b which is acting as a
router so we add a similar entry into
host C's routing table this time we say
to reach network 182 168 1.0 talk to
host B at 192 168 2.6 when we try to
ping now we no longer get the network
unreachable error message that means our
routing entries are right but we still
don't get any response back by default
in Linux packets are not forwarded from
one interface to the next for example
packets received on e 0 on host B are
not forwarded to elsewhere through each
one this is this way for security
reasons for example if you had eats 0
connected to your private network and
each one to a public network we don't
want anyone from the public network to
easily send messages to the private
network unless you explicitly allow that
but in this case since we know that both
our private networks and it is safely
enable communication between them we can
allow host B to forward packets from one
network to the other whether a host can
forward packets between interfaces is
governed by a setting in this system at
file proc says net ipv4 IP underscore
by default the value in this file is set
to zero meaning no forward set this to
one and you should see the pings go
through now remember simply setting this
value does not persist the changes
across rebels for that you must modify
the same value in the Etsy sis
control.com file so let's take away some
key commands from this lecture this will
be handy in the upcoming lectures IP
link is to list and modify interfaces on
the host IP addr command is to see the
IP addresses assigned to those
interfaces IP addr add command is used
to set IP addresses on the interfaces
now remember changes made using these
commands are only valid till a restart
if you want to persist these changes you
must set them in the SC network
interfaces file IP route or simply the
route command is used to view the
routing table and IP route add command
is used to add entries into the routing
table and finally remember the command
to check if IP forwarding is enabled on
a host if you are working with a house
configured as a router in this lecture
we will talk about IP addresses and
ports from a web applications
perspective so one of the common issues
that we've seen students especially
beginners struggle with while working
with web applications are related to
connectivity so what IP addresses do we
use and what are port numbers and what
port numbers to use what is the
difference between localhost 127 dot
0.01 and the IP addresses of the server
or why does it matter and why can't I
access the web server from another
system if there is a web server and
database server then why is one not able
to reach the other so things like these
are some of the common questions that we
get all the time so and through this
lecture I'd like to clarify all of these
and going forward whenever you run into
any similar issues you should be able to
follow these steps and troubleshoot and
fix issues easily
so let's take a step back and understand
a little bit about the basics of
networks and IPS so computer systems
like our laptops or servers have
different kinds of interfaces or
adapters for connectivity such as wired
Ethernet interfaces to connect to a LAN
network through a hub or a switch using
a cable and the wireless interfaces to
connect to the network through Wi-Fi so
irrespective of how they connect to a
network once they do they get an IP
address assigned an IP address is
assigned to an interface in this case we
have a laptop that's connected using an
Ethernet cable to a switch in our home
once the connection is established our
laptop gets an IP address assigned to it
on the network when you run the IP
address show command you see the
interface enp 0 s3 has the IP address
10.0 2.15 now say you have another
adapter a Wi-Fi adapter and you attach
that to the same network but this time
through a Wi-Fi then that interface gets
another IP address assigned to it and
can be seen in the output of the same
command the same laptop now has two
separate IP addresses on the same
network so if any other host in the
network were to try to reach our laptop
they may do so using the any of these IP
addresses each of these network
interface cards are divided into
multiple logical components known as
ports now you can have up to 65535 ports
on each IP address each port is a
communication endpoint programs can
listen on these ports for requests so
when you run a web server it listens for
requests on these interfaces on one of
these ports for instance a Python flask
web server listens on port 5,000 by
default now you can change that by
specifying the port number as a
parameter inside
the run call like this we have now
configured the application to listen on
port 8000 but on what IP address and we
have two IP addresses configured on our
host the port on which of these
interfaces or IP addresses is the
application going to listen on you can
also specify the IP address on which the
server should listen on using the host
option like this the application now
listens on IP 10.0 2.15 on port 8000 so
anyone trying to access my application
on this IP address and port will be able
to view my server however they won't be
able to access the server on the other
interface on IP 10.0 2.16 so what if I
want my application to be available
through both these IPS then instead of
specifying the IP address of a single
interface you must specify 0.0.0.0 in
that case the server will listen on all
available interfaces we now have our
application available on all interfaces
and anyone can access it what if we are
not ready yet to make it available to
the external world for example we are
only developing our application and
don't want anyone else to access it
except for maybe ourselves from within
our laptop in that case remove the host
specification in the application run
call but when we do that it does not
listen on any interface so then how do
we test it by ourselves if it's not
available on any interface what IP do we
use in a browser to access our
application when no option is specified
the server listens on IP 127 dot 0 dot 0
dot 1 by default this is known as the
loopback address apart from the two
interfaces we talked about earlier every
host has a built-in virtual interface
known as the loopback address the
information about this interface is also
visible under the output of the IP
address show command its name
his hello and the IP assigned is 127 dot
zero dot zero dot one every host has
this loopback interface built into it
and all of them have the same IP address
set on it
127 dot zero zero one when you refer to
the IP 127 dot 0 dot 0 dot one it is
like referring to yourself it's like
saying I me or myself anything you sent
to IP 127 dot 0 dot 0 dot one is sent to
the same host nothing sent to this
address leaves the host system so from
within your host if you wish to test
your application you can simply open up
a browser and type in 127 dot 0 dot 0
dot 1 followed by the port at which the
server is listening to access the web
server now instead of typing in the IP
address you can also say local host
because local host is the standard
network name associated with the low
back IP address and that also means that
you cannot access this web server from
any other host other than this host the
127 dot 0 dot 0 dot 1 IP address is an
IP address used to refer to this host
from only within this host every other
host has their own internal loopback
interface with the same IP address of
127 0.01 and if you try to access the
web server using this loopback IP
address from the second host you won't
be able to connect to the first house it
looked for a web server on its own host
which does not exist so the request
fails so remember that this particular
IP address or the host name local host
referred to the local host itself and it
can only be reached from within that
host well that's it for now head over to
the labs and practice working awaits IP
addresses and ports and I will see you
in the next lab
hello and welcome to this lecture in
this lecture we take a look at what
llamo files are if you are familiar with
the ml already feel free to skip this
section and head over to the next
section if you have not worked with
Gamal in the past I would highly
recommend going through this because the
rest of the course depends entirely on
llamo if you have worked with other data
structure formats like XML or JSON you
should be able to easily pick it up
don't worry if you haven't worked on any
of these you should still be able to
easily pick it up going through the
coding exercises that accompany this
course a yellow file is used to
represent data in this case
configuration data here is a quick
comparison of a sample data in three
different formats the one on the left is
XML where we display a list of servers
and their information the same data is
represented in JSON format in the middle
and finally in yellow format to the
right take a minute to compare the three
formats
let's take a close look at llamo if you
take the data in its simplest form such
as key value pair this is how you would
define it in llamo key and value
separated by a colon the keys are fruit
vegetable liquid and meat and the values
are apple carrot water and chicken
remember you must have a space followed
by colon differentiating the key and the
value let's take a look at how an array
is represented we would like to list
some fruits and vegetables we would say
fruits followed by a colon
on the next line enter each item with a
dash in the front the dash indicates
that it's an element of an array how
about a dictionary a dictionary is a set
of properties grouped together under an
item here we try to represent nutrition
information of two fruits the calories
fat and carbs are different for each
fruit notice the blank space before each
item you must have equal number of blank
spaces before the properties of a single
item so they are all aligned together
let's take a closer look at spaces in
llamo here we have a dictionary
representing the nutrition information
of banana the total amount of calories
fat and carbs are shown notice the
number of spaces before each property
that indicates these key value pairs
fall within banana but what if we had
extra spaces for fat and carbs then they
will fall under calories and thus become
properties of calories which doesn't
make any sense
this will result in a syntax error which
will tell you that mapping values are
not allowed here because calories
already have a value set which is 105
you can either set a direct value or a
hash map you cannot have both
so the number of spaces before each
property is key in yeah Mille you must
ensure they're in the right form to
represent your data correctly let's take
it to another level you can have less
containing dictionaries containing lists
in this case I have a list of fruits and
the elements of the list are banana and
grape but each of these element are
further dictionaries containing
nutrition information a lot of students
new to Yama have reached out to me
asking when to use a dictionary or
a list so let me explain this a little
bit better first of all it is important
to understand that all of what we
discussed so far such as XML JSON or
Yama are used to represent data it could
be data about an organization and all of
its employees and their personal details
or it could be data about a school and
all of its students and their grades or
it could be data about an automobile
manufacturing company and all of its
cars and its details it could be
anything let's take an example of a car
a car is a single object and it has
properties such as
color model transition and price to
store different information or
properties of a single object we use a
dictionary in this simple dictionary
I have properties of the car defined in
a key value format this need not be as
simple as this for example in case we
need to split the model further into
model name and make ear
you could then represent this as a
dictionary within another dictionary in
this case the single value of model is
now replaced by a small dictionary with
two properties name and ear so this is
dictionary within another dictionary
let's say we would like to store the
name of six cars the names are formed by
the color and the model of the car to
store this we would use a list or an
array as it is multiple items of the
same type of object since we are only
storing the names we have a simple list
of strings what if we would like to
store all information about each car
everything that we listed before such as
the color model transition and price we
will then modify the array from a list
of strings to a list of dictionaries so
we expand each item in the array and
replace the name with the dictionary we
built earlier this way we are able to
represent all information about multiple
cars in a single yellow file using a
list of dictionaries so that's the
difference between dictionary list and
list of dictionaries I hope you
understood the difference between the
three and when to use each of these
before we head over to exercises let's
take a look at some key notes dictionary
is an unordered collection whereas lists
are ordered collection so what does that
mean the two dictionaries that you see
here have the same properties for banana
however you can see that the order of
properties fat and carbs do not match in
the first dictionary fat is defined
before carbs and in the second
dictionary carbs comes first followed by
fat but that doesn't really matter the
properties can be defined in any order
but the two dictionaries will still be
the same as long as the values of each
property match this is not the same for
lists or arrays arrays are ordered
collection so the order of items matter
the two lists shown are not the same
because apple and banana
are at different positions this is
something to keep in mind while working
with data structures also remember any
line beginning with a hash is
automatically ignored and considered as
a comment we are now ready to head over
to the coding exercises and have fun
playing with mo files
well you've reached the end of the dev
ops prerequisites course congratulations
you now have enough knowledge to get
started with any of the DevOps and cloud
courses out there you'll now be
comfortable working with Linux systems
basic applications basic networking
yamo and other configuration files so
what's the next step you have now
completed the DevOps prerequisites
course in the get your basics right
section the other course available in
this section is the Linux basics course
Linux plays a key role in the DevOps and
cloud world so it's always helpful to
get real good hands-on experience
working with Linux systems our Linux
basics course is a good start and it's
an engaging and fun course developed in
a story format and with lots of hands-on
labs as you did in this course to start
your journey with containers and the
cloud native world get started with the
docker for the absolute beginners course
it's a course that will help you get a
good understanding of the importance of
containers and the role of docker in the
cloud native computing world this course
will pave way to the kubernetes for
beginners course knowledge about
container native technology like docker
is a prerequisite for learning
kubernetes kubernetes is one of the most
trending technology in IT industry as of
today and it's a very in demand skill
once you complete the beginners course
you can target the kubernetes
certifications like CK a and CK ad our
courses have labs and multiple mock
exams that will help you clear
certification easily kubernetes is a
prerequisite for red hat openshift
after completing the CK ad course where
you will learn how to configure and
deploy applications on kubernetes you
can then proceed to the red hat
openshift course
in the automation category start with
the most popular automation tool ansible
are ansible for the absolute beginners
course is targeted for those who have
zero experience in automation or
scripting with this course you will be
able to implement automation solutions
without any experience in coding no
coding or programming experience
required in fact none of these courses
require any kind of coding or
programming experience whatever you have
learned in this DevOps prerequisites
course is sufficient to go through any
of these courses you may choose to learn
other systems like puppet and chef as
well
the ansible for the absolute beginners
course will also help you prepare for
the ansible certification exam and we
plan to have a lot more courses added to
this path in the future so check out
this page whenever you get time we also
have the code cloud engineer program
that will help you get more hands-on
experience this is a simulated job
environment that you can enroll for free
and start while getting tasks assigned
to you for more details check out
engineered code cloud comm well that's
it for now thank you so much for joining
me in this course and I hope to see you
in our next courses